-The Russian invasion of Ukraine
has the world on edge,
as all eyes are on the man
leading the country,
a former comedian turned
president, Volodymyr Zelenskyy.
Here with more
is one of my writers,
a native Russian
who emigrated to America
from the former Soviet Union,
Dina Gusovsky, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, Seth.
That's right.
I am a Russian Jewish refugee.
My family and I fled the former
Soviet Union 30 years ago.
In fact, here's a picture
of me and my mom
right before we came to America.
[ Audience aws ]
Thank you.
Apparently her tickets
to the United States
were good for one woman
and one ventriloquist dummy.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's scary enough
coming to a country
where I did not know
the language and culture,
and it's even more terrifying
that I did it looking like this.
[ Laughter ]
This picture was from the 1990s,
but apparently the cameras
in Russia at the time
were from the 1920s.
To take this picture, I had to
sit still for 30 minutes.
And despite the fact that I did
grow out of being a tiny man,
to this day, I often feel like
a walking contradiction
in America.
I mean, I eat Russian food,
immerse myself in the culture,
and I still speak Russian
every day
to my parents, my grandmother,
and people from Greenpeace
asking me to sign
their petitions.
-Oh, really?
What do you say, Dina?
-[ Speaking Russian ]
-Oh, that really sounds scary.
What does it mean?
-It means, "I don't have time,
but have a wonderful day."
[ Laughter ]
And look, just because
someone in America
speaks Russian
and always looks miserable,
that doesn't mean
that they support Putin.
But I can see how that can be
confusing to non-Russians,
especially since the good guy
and the bad guy
are both named Vladimir.
And despite the fact that
I had been told many times
to "go back to Russia" --
shout-out to
my fifth grade teacher...
[ Audience groans ]
...yeah -- I am so, so grateful
to be an American.
I have never been more proud of
my parents for bringing me here.
And I have never felt luckier
than to work for you, Seth.
-Me?
-To have a comedian as a boss?
President Zelenskyy
is showing everyone
just how brave comedians are.
Right, Seth?
-Uh, uh-huh. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I bet if you could, you would
go to Ukraine right now
and fight alongside
the Ukrainians.
-I -- To-- I mean, yeah.
Wish I could.
-Oh, you can.
-Sorry, what's that?
-You totally can.
Foreign nationals
are not just allowed,
but encouraged to go to Ukraine
to fight for freedom.
I'm just [bleep] with you.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't think you'd go.
Nobody did.
Look, Seth, we can't forget,
this is Putin's war.
And while he might be trying
to divide Russians
and Ukrainians over there,
here in America,
we are united and steadfast
in our support for Ukraine.
I have so many Russian
and Ukrainian immigrant friends.
We speak Russian.
We eat a beet soup
called borsch,
served with sour cream
and raw garlic.
And when we really want to treat
ourselves, sunflower seeds.
Another thing
we have in common --
We're all very close with
our babushkas, our grandmothers.
My grandmother was born
in Kirovohrad, Ukraine,
survived the Holocaust,
and witnessed the Cold War.
She was only able to come
to America in her 60s,
and she happens to be this
country's biggest cheerleader.
This is her.
[ Audience aws ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
She -- She loves America.
And, Seth, it's like
my babushka says.
[ Speaking Russian ]
-Was that just another
harsh-sounding Russian thing
that wasn't so bad?
-No, it means "[Bleep] [bleep]
[bleep] [bleep] [bleep]"
-Dina!
-Sorry.
Grandma's got a filthy mouth.
-Alright, we'll let it go.
Dina Gusovsky, everybody.
We'll be right back.